everyone and welcome to today's poster
presentation rapid by rhett based
colorimetric
assay for protein quantification
presented by ramesh gammopathy R&D
scientist three protein and cell
analysis Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm
Alexis Krause of lab routes and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
well answer as many of your questions is
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know they are
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. ramesh
Ganapathy i will now turn the
presentation over to him
you
hello today I would like to talk about a
rapid by unit based
colorimetric as a pop group for protein
quantification
you
you
the simplest method for protein
quantification is measuring absorbance
at 280 nanometers but this is suitable
only for purified protein samples most
cell biologists need to quantitate cell
or tissue lysate samples the dye based
assays such as Bradford assays are
convenient but they have poor linearity
and poor protein to protein variability
thermo Fisher BCA sa is a copper key
later based assay with exceptional
linearity and low protein to protein
variability a drawback with this assay
is the long time to results so users
have to incubate this at 30 minutes at
37 degrees or for two hours at room
temperature the rapid gold BCA as a
addresses that problem with shorter
incubation time which is 5 minutes at
room temperature it maintains the same
linearity low protein to protein
variability and high accuracy associated
with BCA which shorter time to results
you
this is done exactly like the BCA se
how do we use the rapid gold VCR see so
you pipe it 20 microliters of BSA
standards and your unknown protein
samples to a 96-well plate the rapid
gold BCA working reagent is prepared by
mixing 49 parts of free agent a and one
part of reagent B which is the copper
solution 200 microliters of working
reagent is then added to the standard
and protein samples the flowing plate is
incubated at room temperature for five
minutes and the absorbance is read in an
any standard plate reader at 480
nanometers so we have traditional BCA
which is a highly trusted brand
we have the reducing agents compatible
which is compatible with reducing agents
which is shown in green
we have the micro BCA which is used to
measure small protein concentrations so
this is a high sensitivity product this
is shown in the box in red and now we
have another flavor which is a short
incubation time and room temperature
incubate incubation PCAs a which is the
rapid gold bcx
you
you
this works just like the BCA protein
complexes with copper to to form
proteins copper complex thus reducing
copper to to copper one PC eighty later
then chelate to the radios copper and
the color changes from green to purple
this purple color can be read at an
absorbance of 562 nanometers with rapid
goal BCA we have a proprietary key later
which reacts exactly the same way with
reduced copper but instead of a violet
color it forms an orange brown color the
absorbance of that color can be read at
480 nanometers and these results are
obtained
at room temperature incubation in five
minutes so what we see from the graph is
that we get the same signal intensity
and the same linearity with the rapid
goal BCA which is shown in red to the
traditional BCA which is shown in blue
the only difference is the rapid Goldy
CA was done at room temperature in five
minutes and the traditional BCA was done
at 37 degrees C for 30 minutes so this
is oh very short er of time - results
you
now when compared to other 5-minute
protein Aziz such as a 660 nanometer
assay and Kumasi plus you can see that
the rapid gold BCA showed better
linearity and higher signal intensity
the rapid gold BCA curve is shown in
orange
Kumasi call shown in blue and the 660
nanometer as a curve is shown in green
in the graph
the rapid gold BCA gives similar protein
concentration to unknown Lices as
traditional BCA we can see that the
person cv between these two assays is
five point four two so they give very
very similar results
with pure proteins also there is an
agreement between the rapid goal BCA and
the traditional BCA similar accuracy is
seen between rapid goal BCA and
traditional BCA
and we see an 18.6% CV with PCA and
13.7% CV with the rapid gold VCS when
compared to the theoretical
concentrations so this theoretical
concentration is how we measure accuracy
and the theoretical concentration for
each of these protein mixes was obtained
you by measuring absorbance at 280
nanometers another thing to note here is
that we see very low protein to protein
variability with rapid gold BCA and BCA
with 14 different proteins
the dye based assays show very high
protein to protein variability which is
undesirable
you
so in conclusions the rapid copper
chelation assay was developed five
minutes at room temperature is
sufficient to get good signal intensity
with excellent linearity low protein to
protein variability is seen with the new
assay and there is an agreement with
concentration values between the rapid
goal BCA and traditional BCA in addition
to all these features this is a highly
accurate as a
thank you very much
thank you dr. Ganapathy for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is what is the compatibility of
the rapid gold DCA
rapid core BCA is compatible with
detergents so you can use any detergents
up to five percent for example five
person SDS it's compatible with most of
our lysis buffers but it is not
compatible with reducing agents so if
you have reducing agents in your samples
you need to remove that first before
using the assay or you can you can go
for other protein assays which are not
which are more reducing agent compatible
if we also have a reducing agent
compatible be CSA so you could opt for
that if you have reducing agents such as
DDT or t7 your samples
now this is going to be a two-part
question what absorbance range can be
used to read the rapid gold PCA and does
it have to be read only at 480
nanometers know if your blade reader
does not have the capability to read
exactly at 480 nanometers you could
select the range we have done a study
and we think that anything from 470
nanometers all the way up to 530
nanometers can be used to can be used
with the rapid go BCA
can rapid gold be ca be use to measure
very low concentration samples like the
micro be ca can know it's not as
sensitive as a micro BCA there is ways
that we could try to optimize the sample
volume and try to get that kind of
sensitivity but the product as it is
right now
it's not as sensitive as the micro BCS a
and if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr.
Ganapathy for his presentation I would
also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific we're making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
our debate viewing through September of
2019 please share that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye